so over here we have the graph of y is
equal to G of X and what I want to do is
I want to figure out the limit of G of X
as X approaches positive 6 from values
that are less than positive 6 or you
could say from the left from the you say
the negative direction so what is this
going to be equal to and if you have a
sense of it pause the video and give a
go at it well to think about this let's
just a pro let's just take different X
values that approach 6 from the left and
look at what the values of the function
are so G of 2 looks like it's a little
bit more than 1 G of 3 it's a little bit
more than that G of 4 looks like it's a
little under 2 G of 5 it looks like it's
around 3 G of 5.5 looks like it's around
5 gia let's say five point seven five
looks like it's like nine and so as X
gets closer and closer to 6 from the
left it looks like the value of our
function just gets comes unbounded it's
just getting infinitely large and so in
some context you might see someone write
that maybe this is equal to infinity but
infinity isn't it we're not talking
about a specific number and if we're if
we're talking technically about limits
the way that we've looked at it what is
you'll sometimes see this in some
classes but in this context especially
on the exercises on Khan Academy we'll
say that this does not exist not exist
this thing right over here is unbounded
and this is interesting because the left
handed limit here doesn't exist but the
right handed limit does if I were to say
the limit of G of X as X approaches 6
from the right hand side well let's see
we have G of 8 is there G of 7 is there
G of 6.5 looks like it's a little less
than negative 3 G of 6.0 one little even
closer to negative 3 G of 6 point zero
zero zero zero zero zero one it's very
close to Nega
of three so it looks like this limit
right over here at least looking at it
graphically it looks like when we
approach 6 from the right looks like the
function is approaching negative 3 but
from the left it's just unbounded so
we'll say it doesn't exist